North Korea's latest missile launch has
drawn condemnation from Japan South
Korea and the U.S with Washington
calling it dangerous the nuclear-capable
ballistic missile is the first to fly
over Japan in five years South Korea and
the U.S responded by firing
surface-to-air missiles off the east
coast the U.S also ran joint drills with
Japan where Rob McBride joins us live
now from the South Korean capital Seoul
uh Rob so what more can you tell us
about the broader response to North
Korea's latest missile launch
that's right well South Korea had
promised a Resolute response to a
Tuesday's launch from its military and
overnight Tuesday into Wednesday local
time we have seen what that response is
with the firing of these four missiles
from South Korea's East Coast out into
the sea that separates the Korean
Peninsula from Japan we're told that two
were fired by U.S forces too by South
Korean forces they are said to have been
surface to surface missiles which hit
their targets out at Sea there was also
Tuesday a joint air drill by U.S and
South Korean Air Forces the flying
drills over on the other side of the
Korean peninsula in the Yellow Sea that
separates the Korean Peninsula from
China apparently a South Korean F-15
fighter jet dropped two guided bombs on
a bombing range out in in an island in
the Yellow Sea the first we knew about
the launch of the missiles came from
residents in Gangnam the city on the
East Coast reporting on social media
hearing these launches happen are also
reporting a large explosion and a
fireball with images being released on
social media appearing to show this
explosion within the confines of a
military base and it does appear as
though a missile
exploded on launch or just after launch
the South Korean military says it is
looking into it but it is highly
embarrassing for the South Korean
military here this all comes at a time
of escalating tensions of course uh with
the uh with the launch of Tuesday's
missile an intermediate missile over the
top of Japan possibly in response to
Navy drills that have been happening off
the east coast and we're told that the
one of the ships taking part in that
that Ronald Reagan the first aircraft
carrier to be deployed on exercise in
five years has now actually been turned
around and sent back to the EC the Sea
of Japan because of the current increase
intentions all right Rob McBride live us
there from Seoul Rob thank you
several countries including the US have
called for an emergency un security
council meeting to respond to the
North's growing threat
we condemn
this dangerous and Reckless launch of a
long-range ballistic missile that flew
over Japan and it posed an unacceptable
threat to the Japanese public this
action is a clear violation of multiple
resolutions adopted by the U.N security
Council and it again demonstrates the
threat that the dprk
holds both as it relates to its unlawful
weapons of mass destruction program but
also its ballistic missions program and
the threat that it poses to its
neighbors as well Mike Hannah has more
now from Washington D.C
very strong reaction those words are
dangerous and Reckless were echoed by
all branches of the Biden Administration
that was stated that the White House we
heard it from the Pentagon and also
there from the state department uh the
senior leaders of the administration the
Secretary of Defense the National
Security adviser uh all have been in
touch with their counterparts in the
region as indicating the depth of the
concern about this but the reaction to
the latest missile launch was Swift U.S
forces joined South Korean forces in
terms of conducting exercises in South
Korea itself brandishing its own missile
systems in a show of strength and a
demonstration that it would not be
outgunned by its neighbor on the
peninsula at the same time as well in
the wake of the missile test the U.S
marine Fighters fought flu exercises
with Japanese fighter aircraft over the
Sea of Japan was a co-order donated and
massive reaction to the latest missile
launch or missile test remembering that
there have been some 40 tests by the
North Koreans since the beginning of the
year that is 42 missiles fired from 20
separate missile tests and there's
mounting concern within the United
States and of course South Korea and
Japan with this ongoing what is viewed
as provocation by the neighbors of North
Korea